Die Leute, die man ruft, wenn's
wirklich brenzlig ist, auf die man sich wirklich
verlassen können muss, wenn die rechtsextreme
Chats betreiben
untereinander, wenn Vorgesetzte
das wissen, nicht dagegen eintreten,
nicht einschreiten, dann von einem
Geschmäckle zu sprechen, das ist schon
total untertrieben. Das ist für mich
ein institutionelles Versagen.
Ich starte direkt mit der ersten Frage
von 13 Fragen, mit der Konfliktfrage: Versagen
staatliche Institutionen im Kampf
gegen Rechtsextremismus? Wenn ihr sagt: Ja,
die versagen - dann könnt ihr aufs
grüne Feld gehen. Und wenn ihr sagt: Nee,
das kann man so nicht sagen - dann
könnt ihr aufs gelbe Feld gehen. Okay,
dann wissen wir, wo ihr steht. Der rechtsextreme
Terroranschlag in Hanau
auf eine Synagoge in Halle oder der Mord
an Walter Lübke in Kassel, all
das passiert in weniger als einem
Jahr und macht deutlich, Deutschland hat
ein Problem mit Rechtsextremismus.
Die NSU-Morde, Angriffe auf Unterkünfte
für Geflüchtete oder auch die Ausschreitungen
in Chemnitz zeigen
außerdem, er ist und war schon immer
allgegenwärtig. Viele sind der Meinung,
dass vor allem staatliche
Institutionen, also Polizei, Bundeswehr und Justiz
im Kampf gegen rechten Terror
immer wieder versagen. Andere sind wiederum
der Meinung, dass die ziemlich gut
aufgestellt sind. Bei 13 Fragen sind sich
meine Gäste erstmal uneinig.
Umso spannender wird es sein: Werden
sie am Ende dann doch einen
Kompromiss finden, wie wir rechten Terror
in Deutschland besser bekämpfen
können? Oder vielleicht sogar eine Lösung?
Wir werden sehen. Wo würdet ihr euch
hinstellen? Seid ihr der Meinung,
dass die staatlichen Institutionen
versagen im Kampf gegen rechten Terror?
Ja oder nein, grün oder gelb? Schreibt
es mir gerne mal in die Kommentare. Dann gilt
für euch ab jetzt, wenn ihr der anderen
Seite zustimmen wollt, dann könnt
ihr einen Schritt auf sie zugehen ins nächste
Kästchen oder auch innerhalb eurem
Kästchen. Und wenn ihr sauer seid über
etwas, was jemand anders sagt, dann könnt
ihr auch währenddessen einen Schritt
zurückgehen. Und mein Ziel ist natürlich,
am Ende so viele von euch hier im Kompromissfeld
zu sehen. Für mich wäre
es gut. Ruben, ich möchte mit dir
beginnen. Du bist in einer traditionell
jüdischen Familie in Frankfurt am Main
geboren und aufgewachsen. Du setzt dich
ein für eine jüdische Gemeinde,
gegen Antisemitismus, gegen Diskriminierung.
Kannst du den Moment
beschreiben, als du von dem Anschlag in Halle
-auf eine Synagoge gehört hast?
-Das kann ich tatsächlich sehr, sehr gut.
Und zwar war ich da gerade im Gottesdienst
in der Synagoge und hatte mein Handy,
so wie es üblich ist, aus. Und es hat
sich so eine Unruhe generell in der ganzen
Synagoge ausgebreitet. Aber niemand
wusste genau, was passiert ist. Und dann bin
ich nach Hause gegangen in der Zeit
zwischen den beiden Gebeten.
Und als ich abends dann wieder in Richtung
Synagoge gegangen bin, war viel mehr
Polizei vor Ort, bewaffnete
Beamt_innen. Und ab da wusste ich, irgendetwas ist
passiert. Und es war für mich ein Schock,
aber es war keine Überraschung,
weil dieser Anschlag in einer Kontinuität
rechten Terrors in Deutschland steht.
Staatliche Institutionen versagen im Kampf
gegen Rechtsextremismus, weil die Gefahr
seit Jahren unterschätzt wird
und gleichermaßen auch die Gesellschaft
in diesem Kampf versagt, weil die Bedrohung
einfach nicht ernst genommen
-wird.
-Ruben sagt also, es war für ihn keine
Überraschung. Würdet ihr ihm da zustimmen?
Geht ihr erst einmal einen Schritt
auf Ruben zu? So halb. Warum war
das nur so ein halber kleiner Schritt?
Weil die Grundsatzfrage natürlich die ist:
Wer hätte es denn voraussehen können?
Und gerade in dem konkreten Fall. Na
klar, es gab eine abstrakte Gefährdung schon
seit vielen Jahren. Nicht
nur die jüdischen Gemeinden,
sondern auch die Sicherheitsbehörden
haben davor gewarnt. Aber diesen konkreten
Überfall auf die Synagogengemeinde
in Halle, den konnte nun wirklich niemand
-voraussehen.
-Daniel.
Ich kann das eigentlich auch nur bekräftigen.
Letztendlich können
wir nur sozusagen mit den Instrumenten
arbeiten, die uns gegeben sind. Und dazu
gehört es eben nicht, dass wir alles
vorhersehen können, sondern gerade
bei der Polizei ist natürlich auch viel
Reaktion am Ende dabei. Es gibt sicherlich
Fehler, die passiert sind und auch Fehler,
die passieren und Defizite,
die wir abstellen müssen in den Sicherheitsbehörden.
Aber Versagen ist
absolut und das kann man nicht
behaupten, da wir auch sehr erfolgreich
Rechtsextremisten sowohl beim
Verfassungsschutz beobachten
als auch polizeilich
strafrechtlich verfolgen.
Ruben, was macht das mit dir,
wenn du das hörst?
Es macht ein bisschen ein mulmiges
Gefühl, weil ich glaube, auf den konkreten
Anschlag, vielleicht auf viele
andere Anschläge, Walter Lübke beispielsweise,
glaube ich schon, dass man da mit konkreteren
Maßnahmen Sachen verhindern
hätte können. Das Gleiche gilt für Hanau.
Ich glaube, da läuft einiges schief.
Nemi, kannst du dich denn noch an den Terroranschlag
in Hanau erinnern,
an den Moment, wo du davon
erfahren hast? Und kannst du dich auch noch
an die Reaktion der migrantischen
Community erinnern?
Also es war eine Katastrophe für einen.
Ich bin mit einem Freund unterwegs gewesen
und ich weiß noch, wie ich zu ihm
gesagt hab: Krass, an dir wäre er vorbeigelaufen,
weil mein Freund blond war, aber mich
hätte er wahrscheinlich getroffen. Das war
so eine Unmittelbarkeit, die einfach
krass ist. Und war das für dich so ähnlich,
wie Ruben gerade gesagt hat,
keine Überraschung, oder? Nee, ich glaube,
rechtsterroristische Anschläge in Deutschland
überraschen mich, um ehrlich
zu sein, nicht. Also spätestens
seit dem NSU, seit Rostock-Lichtenhagen,
seit Solingen. Es gibt so viele
Attentate, die sich immer wieder summieren. Und eins
folgt auf den nächsten. Also man
fragt sich im Grunde genommen, glaube
ich und auch in der migrantischen
Community nur: Wann passiert
das das nächste Mal? Ich würde
nicht sagen, dass der deutsche Staat
auf dem rechten Auge komplett blind
ist, aber ich glaube, es gibt erhebliche
Defizite, die es aufzuarbeiten
gilt. Beispielsweise fallen immer wieder
rechtsextreme Chatgruppen von Polizisten,
auch von Spezialeinheiten auf.
Ich denke, wir müssen ein bisschen
vielleicht vorsichtig sein und das Thema
abschichten. Ich glaube, wir sind uns
einig, schon in der alten Bundesrepublik
hat der Rechtsterrorismus eine Blutspur
hinterlassen bei vielen Gelegenheiten.
Und da fallen mir auch einige
jüdische Opfer ein. Du hast eben
von Rostock-Lichtenhagen gesprochen.
Auch das waren alles Dinge, die uns eigentlich
hätten nicht nur schmerzen müssen,
sondern die uns hätten klarmachen müssen,
hier sind gravierende Fehler passiert
in den Behörden. Aber die Grundsatzfrage ist
die: Wie wird jemand zu einem
Extremisten in einer Gesellschaft? Egal
welches politische Phänomen. Und da sage
ich: Niemand wird als Antisemit
oder als Extremist geboren, sondern eine Gesellschaft
macht Menschen erst dazu.
Und da sage ich ganz offen, wenn wir argumentativ
sagen, die Behörden haben
versagt oder Teile der Behörden
haben versagt, dann müssen wir mindestens
genauso deutlich sagen, auch diese Gesellschaft
hat versagt. Ich mache gerne
eine Diskussion mit denjenigen
auf, die der Ansicht sind, dass staatliche
Institutionen versagt haben, um auch deutlich
zu machen, dass ich einerseits
natürlich Fehler erkenne,
furchtbare Fehler, die zu ganz furchtbaren
Konsequenzen geführt haben, NSU ist
nur ein Stichwort, aber auch Walter Lübke.
Aber auf der anderen Seite
möchte ich schon mit ihnen diskutieren,
um zu beleuchten aus den unterschiedlichen
Blickwinkeln, was zu tun ist, um überhaupt
Rechtsextremismus und Terrorismus
zu begegnen.
Axel, ich würde dir gerne eine Frage
stellen. Und zwar bist du mit 13 Jahren
in die rechte Szene gekommen.
Kannst du das mal erklären, wie landet man
in der rechten Szene? Wie kommt
man da rein, vor allem auch so jung?
Also letztlich ist es immer, wenn junge
Menschen, ich war 13 Jahre alt wie gesagt,
in die Szene kommen, selten
aus Überzeugung, sondern meistens
aufgrund von Bauchgefühl. Und ich hatte
damals in der Schule ein Projekt,
für das ich die nicht im Bundestag
vertretenen Parteien die Wahlprogramme
organisieren sollte, um eine Collage
damit zu machen. Habe das mit großem Eifer getan
und die Lehrerin hat mir dafür auch eine 1
gegeben. Aber hat eben dann die rechten
Parteien, Republikaner, NPD und DVU
zur damaligen Zeit, dann runtergenommen
mit dem Vermerk: Ja, den geben wir hier
keine Plattform. Und das hat Interesse
bei mir geweckt. Ich hab dann die Parteien
angeschrieben, die NPD hat sich bei mir
zurückgemeldet und so hab ich dann
angefangen, kritische Fragen im Unterricht
zu stellen. Und darauf wurde dann
nicht mit mir diskutiert, sondern eben dann: Du
bist jetzt still, du hältst die Klappe,
das wird hier nicht verbreitet.
Eine Ungerechtbehandlung, so hab ich das damals
empfunden. Und da hat die Szene
dann angesetzt, die rechtsextreme
Szene und sagte: Schau an, du stellst
nur Fragen, dir wird über den Mund
gefahren, mit dir wird nicht diskutiert.
Das ist doch keine echte
Demokratie, in der wir leben. Und schon war
ich in dieser Szene drin. Und ja,
leider dann 15 Jahre lang geblieben. Das Thema
liegt mir deswegen am Herzen, weil ich selber
ja eine Schuld auf mich geladen
habe. Ich bin jahrelang
Organisator, Netzwerker und Hetzredner gewesen
in dieser Szene. Ich habe junge
Menschen dazu gebracht, in dieser Szene sich
zu betätigen und habe deren Geist
vergiftet mit Hassparolen. Ich distanziere
mich heute ganz klar von Rechtsextremismus
wie von jedem extremistischen Gedankengut.
Ich verurteile den Rassismus, ich verurteile
die Menschenfeindlichkeit,
ich verurteile das Ausschließlichkeitsdenken
und deswegen ist
es nur recht und billig, dass ich heute
meinen Teil dazu beitrage und sage: Es tut
mir leid, was ich gemacht habe.
Macht bitte nicht dieselben Fehler,
-wie ich sie gemacht habe.
-Du stehst aber trotzdem auf der gelben
Seite, d.h. du bist der Meinung, dass die staatlichen
Institutionen beim Kampf
gegen Rechtsextremismus
nicht versagt haben. Warum?
Aus eigener Erfahrung kann ich sagen
- ich habe sehr viele Kundgebungen,
Demonstrationen angemeldet und veranstaltet
und hatte da natürlich
auch einen intensiven Kontakt mit Behörden
seien es Polizeipräsidien, seien
es Versammlungsbehörden - und ich habe
das wirklich nie erlebt, dass da eine,
wenn auch unterschwellige Sympathie
geäußert worden wäre. Im Gegenteil, da ist
immer ganz klar gemacht worden: Okay,
ihr dürft euer Recht in Anspruch nehmen,
aber wir machen es euch nicht einfach.
Und ich habe auch die Strafverfolgung selber
erlebt, wo ich gesehen habe, dass da schon
mit Argusaugen darüber gewacht wurde,
was Leute dann eben an Straftaten
begehen. Die sind in der Szene allgegenwärtig
und so kann ich nicht sagen, dass der Staat
da versagt hat. Natürlich gibt
es immer Versäumnisse. Gerade die angesprochenen
Themen haben ja gezeigt,
dass da die Behörden auch nicht immer
in der wünschenswerten Klarheit Stellung
-bezogen haben.
-Nemi, ist denn deiner Meinung nach die
-Polizei auf dem rechten Auge blind?
-Ich würde nicht unbedingt sagen, dass die
Polizei auf dem rechten Auge blind
ist, aber es gibt erhebliche Defizite,
die es auf jeden Fall aufzuarbeiten
gilt. Abgesehen davon ist auch die Polizei immer
wieder durchsetzt von Menschen mit rechten
Einstellungen oder rechtsextremen
Einstellungen. Immer wieder
fallen Chatgruppen auf. Vor kurzem wurde
das Frankfurter SEK aufgelöst. Die Sicherheitsbehörden
oder die Menschen,
die in diesen Sicherheitsbehörden
arbeiten, sind nicht gefeit davor,
rechtsextreme Einstellungen an den Tag
zu legen. Also die Leute, die man ruft,
wenn's wirklich brenzlig ist, auf die man
sich wirklich verlassen können muss,
wenn die rechtsextreme Chats betreiben
untereinander, wenn Vorgesetzte das wissen
und nicht eintreten oder nicht
dagegen eintreten, nicht einschreiten, also
ich finde, von einem
Geschmäckle zu sprechen, das ist schon total
untertrieben. Das ist für mich
ein institutionelles Versagen.
Bevor der Polizist selber vielleicht
mal ein paar Worte dazu sagt: Ich meine,
man muss so fair sein, das sieht man
ja jetzt fast wöchentlich, wenn die nächsten
Skandale über Chatgruppen und andere
Sachen herauskommen, das viel zu lange
wir, glaube ich, ein Ausbildungs-,
ein Weiterbildungs- und ein Führungsproblem
-in der Polizei hatten.
-Also das kann ich auch bestätigen.
Die große Mehrheit sind auf dem Boden
der Demokratie. Aber die, die dabei sind,
verderben nicht nur das Ganze, sondern was sagen
denn die anderen, die eigentlich
nicht so gesehen werden wollen? Da wäre
vielleicht unsere Polizeikollege -
Die Chatgruppen sind nie durch
irgendwelche anderen Polizistinnen
aufgeflogen, sondern immer
durch andere Sachen wie beispielsweise
Kinderpornographie oder irgendwas
anderes. Sie sind nie aufgekommen,
weil irgendjemand gesagt hat: Hey,
das ist nicht in Ordnung und ich gehe damit
irgendwie an die Öffentlichkeit,
im Gegenteil.
Einspruch, Euer Ehren. Du hast zwar
recht, in der Mehrzahl der Fälle ist es von außen
aufgedeckt worden. Aber ich muss
ehrenhalber schon sagen, ich kenne einige
Polizisten und Polizistinnen,
ihnen wurde es schlimm und schwer zugetan,
weil sie in der Truppe dann
ausgesondert wurden, die den Mut hatten, Dinge auch ans
Tageslicht zu führen. Aber ich gebe
euch recht, die Mehrzahl ist von außen
-gekommen.
-Aber genau deswegen braucht es doch
Strukturen, wo sich z.B. Beamte,
die sich auf dem Boden der freiheitlichen
Grundordnung bewegen, hinwenden können,
die nicht polizeiintern sozusagen arbeiten
und die extern ausgelagert
eigene Ermittlungskompetenzen haben.
Stattdessen müssen Polizisten
gegen Polizisten ermitteln und derjenige,
der sozusagen als Nestbeschmutzer
gilt, der etwas sagt, der sich traut, der wird
ausgesondert, der wird ausgegrenzt
und wird seines Lebens nicht mehr froh.
Ist das etwas, was du unterstützen
würdest oder was du verstehen kannst?
Ich will nur sagen, man muss mit den Ressourcen,
die wir haben, auch arbeiten
und die Rahmenbedingungen haben
die Sicherheitsbehörden nicht alleine
in der Hand. Das ist erst
einmal festzuhalten. Und wenn ich möchte,
dass Rechtsextremismus vernünftig
bekämpft wird, muss ich die Sicherheitsbehörden
ausstatten - politische Aufgabe. Und das,
was ihr gesagt habt, da bin ich sofort
dabei. Wir müssen neben dem, was der Verfassungsschutz
jetzt schon macht -
zu gucken, was haben wir an Extremisten
in den Behörden - müssen wir natürlich
auch wissenschaftlich reingucken, auch sozusagen
in einem Level, was jetzt nicht
strafrechtlich relevant ist,
sondern auch vorher schon. Wenn jemand einen
rassistischen Spruch macht, ist er nicht
automatisch ein Rechtsextremist, aber
-er gehört trotzdem betrachtet.
-Ja, deswegen wäre eine Studie des
Innenministeriums auch nett gewesen
dazu. Stattdessen bekommen wir eine Studie über
den Polizeialltag, genauso wichtig oder zumindest
auch wichtig, aber das ist nicht
-die Frage.
-Die ist leider nicht weitgehend genug.
Aber ich denke auch, wir müssen
schauen, dass wir da insgesamt uns breiter
aufstellen, dass wir Wissenschaft
dauerhaft zulassen und nicht sozusagen -
-Also stimmst du Nemi da zu in dem Punkt?
-Ja, deswegen bin ich ja vorhin nach vorne
-gegangen.
-Wir sind alle schon ganz schön weit nach
-vorn gekommen hier.
-Und auch das als letzter Punkt: Ich stimme
auch zu mit einer unabhängigen
Untersuchung und mit einem
Polizeibeauftragten, der auch tatsächlich
diesen Namen verdient hat. Und das ist
bei Weitem noch nicht so, dass wir das überall
haben, denn die Anonymität
von Kolleginnen und Kollegen, die sich
dort hinwenden, ist nicht überall sicher.
Und das ist ein Problem. Also da sind
wir, glaube ich, ziemlich dicht beieinander.
Florian, du hast dich ja intensiv
mit Rechtsextremismus in Deutschland
auseinandergesetzt und auch ein Buch
darüber geschrieben. Würdest du sagen,
dass rechter Terror 2021 auch vielleicht
eine ganz andere Dimension angenommen hat?
Eine neue Dimension, denn es gibt
ja weiterhin diesen analogen
Rechtsextremismus. Das haben wir ja
gesehen mit dem Fall NSU. Und es gab ja
auch jemanden, der früher in der rechten
Szene war, nämlich der Mörder von Walter
Lübke, den ich auch zu diesen analogen
Rechtsextremismus zähle. Aber es gibt eben
auch zusätzlich diese Dimension der virtuellen
Radikalisierung, wo man dann
letzten Endes sich dann nicht mehr
auf die örtliche Kameradschaft bezieht,
sondern eben auf einen Breivik.
Und übrigens der Täter von Halle hat ja
auch ein Vorbild, nämlich zum einen
Breivik und den Täter von Christchurch.
Ursprünglich hatte er sogar überlegt,
nach Christchurch eine Moschee anzugreifen.
Also diese Täter inspirieren sich
gegenseitig in diesen virtuellen Räumen.
Ich habe mich sehr intensiv mit dem Thema
einzelne Wölfe, der neue Terrorismus
rechter Einzeltäter beschäftigt,
mit dem Phänomen des sozial isolierten,
-aber virtuell vernetzten Mannes.
-Und magst du da mal kurz den Unterschied
erklären, einfach damit es alle, auch die Zuschauer_innen
verstehen können: Was ist
denn der Unterschied zwischen einem
Einzeltäter, einer Einzeltäterin und einem
-einsamen Wolf?
-Da muss ich gleich sagen, ich weiß dass
Sie jetzt gendern, das ist auch gut und schön.
In dem Fall passt es nicht. Es gibt
keine einsame Wölfin. Es sind
nämlich alles Männer. Und Frauenhass spielt
eine sehr, sehr wichtige Rolle in diesem Radikalisierungsprozess.
Sie sagen
teilweise, dass sie niemals in ihrem
Leben eine Beziehung hatten. Der Täter von Hanau
schreibt in seinem Manifest, dass er einmal
in seinem Leben ein Date hatte.
Also das ist ein Männerphänomen. Und der Unterschied
ist eben, dass diese Täter
sehr stark auf Spieleplattformen
aktiv sind und letzten Endes sich dann
auch selber radikalisieren. Der Täter
von Hanau hat sich sehr stark über YouTube
radikalisiert. Der Täter von München
oder der Täter von Halle, die waren sehr stark
auf Steam aktiv und in diesen einschlägigen
Chats und dann
auch mit diesen Symbolen wie Techno-Barbarian
Girl und auch der starke
Antisemitismus, der in diesen Vorreden
eine wichtige Rolle spielt.
Wie auch andere Behörden,
Sicherheitsbehörden in den USA, schon seit
einiger Zeit feststellen, dass hier
verschlüsselt kommuniziert wird.
Deswegen ist es natürlich
wichtig, auf der einen Seite, dass wir über
WhatsApp-Gruppen bei der Polizei
sprechen. Aber das ist eben ein anderes Phänomen.
Diesen Katalog, den du gerade sehr schön
aufgezählt hast - "hat sich bei YouTube
radikalisiert, hat ein Manifest
vorher veröffentlicht, hat Beziehungsprobleme
gehabt, wir haben es bis jetzt nur mit Männern
zu tun" - das alles heißt aber
nicht, dass wenn wir diese Punkte
in unser Raster reinsetzen, wir todsicher
den nächsten erwischen. Wir können
auch heute gar nicht sagen, ob es nicht
vielleicht in Zukunft auch eine lonesome
Woman ist. Wir erleben z.B. gerade
im Bereich des Links- aber auch des
Rechtsextremismus, habe gerade letzte
Woche einen Vortrag darüber
gehalten, die Rolle der Frauen
-in dem Extremismusbereich.
-Sunsanne G. ist ja jetzt vom "Dritten Weg"
-angeklagt.
-Wir wissen vom Islamismus, dass Frauen
selber nicht nur als Briefträger,
sondern als Anschlägerinnen, als diejenigen
Täterinnen auftreten. Deswegen mein Petitum
an der Stelle ist nur: Ja,
wir lernen alle und Behörden
sollten besonders schnell lernen und wir haben
in vielen Bereichen leider noch
nicht gelernt, wirklich, gestehe ich ein.
Aber wir sollen bitte nicht so
tun, als wenn es schon die festen Lösungen
und Antworten auf all die Fragen
gibt, die in den Schubladen sind.
Ich würde dazu gern etwas Wichtiges
anmerken. Ich selber als rechtsextremer
Agitator weiß ja, was für eine Sprache
in der Szene gepflegt wird. Und verbaler
Totschläger ist jeder
Rechtsextremist. Das heißt, von den 34 000 bekannten
Rechtsextremisten wird jeder schon
einmal geschrieben haben: "Knüpft sie am nächsten
Baum auf. Wir müssen mehr machen,
Wahlen bringen nichts, lass zur Waffe greifen."
Es ist natürlich dann sehr, sehr schwierig
bei diesem Wust von Verbalradikalität
herauszufiltern, wer schreitet jetzt
zur Tat und wer produziert jetzt einfach nur,
damit er Applaus von seinen
Kameraden bekommt? Ich denke, das kann auch keine
Behörde der Welt tatsächlich
übersehen, gerade wenn das Feld noch viel weiter
ausgeweitet wird auf soziale
Plattformen, wo in der Anonymität in jeder Hinsicht
Leute sehr schnell viel radikaler
und viel extremer werden, da auch genau
auszudifferenzieren, "der ist
jetzt eine Gefahr, da müssen wir gucken,
dass er keinen Anschlag begeht",
oder "ja gut, das ist jetzt ein 15-Jähriger,
der rumtrollt und sich damit
wichtig machen will." Ich denke mal,
wenn wir keinen Polizeistaat haben
wollen, muss man tatsächlich immer auch, so blöd
das klingt, Learning by Doing
machen, um Dinge auszuforschen, genauer nachher
zu erkennen, da sind Schritte gewesen,
die haben wir vorher nicht im Blickfeld gehabt
und jetzt erkennen wir erst einmal,
okay, da müssen wir künftig genau hinsehen.
Aber dann stelle ich mir die Frage,
wie fast 400 Rechtsextreme einfach
untertauchen können. Und da ist
mein Lieblingsbeispiel Attila Hildmann,
der wahrscheinlich der prominenteste
Rechtsextreme ist, der alles Mögliche
von Morddrohungen, Beleidigungen,
Volksverhetzung und so weiter und so fort
in aller Öffentlichkeit über ein Jahr
lang der ganzen Welt im Endeffekt preisgegeben
hat, wie es dann sein kann,
dass er in die Türkei ausreisen kann.
Wie kann jemand wie Attila
Hildmann denn dann noch frei rumlaufen?
Es ist tatsächlich ein bisschen
Spekulation, weil wir ja die Wege nicht
kennen, wie er darüber geht.
Letztendlich wie viele andere Kriminelle auch schaffen
es immer mal wieder welche
auch sozusagen durchzuschlüpfen.
Was muss passieren, damit da niemand
mehr durchschlüpfen kann oder zumindest so
-wenige wie möglich?
-Es wird kein Niemand irgendwann geben. Wir
müssen uns einfach mit der Realität
anfreunden. Wir werden keine absolute
Sicherheit hinbekommen. Dass wir besser
werden können und nach Möglichkeit eben
diese Fehler, die jetzt passiert
sind, auch wirklich aufzuarbeiten, was noch
lange nicht begonnen hat, da bin ich ganz
bei euch. Aber wir sollten nicht so tun,
als wenn alles nur Müll wäre. Ich könnte
jetzt, was ich leider nicht darf,
zwei Beispiele bringen, wo wir gerade
in den letzten vier Wochen, drei Behörden,
zwei 14-Jährige gefunden haben, die zu Hause
in ihrer eigenen elterlichen Wohnung
Waffen und Sprengstoff gehortet
haben, wo wir es verhindern konnten.
-Darüber schreibt niemand.
-Ihr habt ja gerade schon fleißig zumindest
immer wieder versucht,
Kompromissvorschläge auszutauschen
oder Ideen, Möglichkeiten, was man
machen könnte, um rechten Terror in Deutschland
vielleicht besser zu bekämpfen. Und das ist
jetzt genau mein Stichwort, denn
ich möchte die Kompromissrunde
eröffnen, in der ich euch ein Kompromissvorschlag
mitteilen werde und mal gucken, ob ihr auf mich
zugeht einen Schritt. Das Personal
in staatlichen Behörden ist noch
nicht gut genug ausgebildet, um rechten Terror
effizient zu bekämpfen. Können wir uns
deshalb darauf einigen, dass speziell
im Kampf gegen den rechten
Terror zugeschnittene Ausbildungsprogramme
bei der Polizei etabliert werden
müssen? Wenn ihr sagt "Ja", dann könnt ihr jetzt
einen Schritt auf mich zugehen. Ruben
Du bist keinen Schritt auf mich zugegangen,
-warum?
-Weil ich glaube, dass es mehr als
Ausbildung innerhalb der Polizei
und Sicherheitsbehörden braucht. Das kann
ein Schritt sein, aber ich glaube,
es braucht dort nochmal viel systemischere
-Wandlungen als nur explizite Ausbildung.
-Stefan, auch du hast dich nicht bewegt.
Ruben hat es schon gut
zusammengefasst, was auch ich - Ja, ich bin für Ausbildung
-sehr zu haben, aber
-Nicht nur.
in dem Blumenstrauss nur ein Blümchen
sein. Okay, dann könnt ihr jetzt gerne
nach den weiteren Blümchen suchen und die Köpfe
zusammenstecken und euch einen
neuen, vielleicht besseren
Kompromissvorschlag überlegen.
-Die Zivilgesellschaft auf der einen Seite
-oder zumindest mit konservativer Gesinnung
-Waffenliebhaber
-auch andere Programme geschaffen werden
müssen, die Leute wieder
zurück in die Gesellschaft zu holen.
So es ist auf jeden Fall nicht
einfach, bei dem Thema jetzt Kompromissvorschläge
zu finden. Ich weiß nicht, ob hier
zu Hause gerade vielleicht noch Ideen
in eurem Kopf habt. Ich bin
gespannt, welche Lösungen hier gleich von beiden
-Seiten präsentiert werden.
-Also ich sehe den Verfassungsschutz als
Institution super
kritisch. Willst du vorstellen?
-Kann ich gerne machen, ja.
-Ich möchte euch jetzt, die grüne Seite,
fragen: Zu welchen Kompromissvorschlag
seid ihr gekommen?
Also unser Kompromiss wäre, dass wir eine differenziertere
Debatte anbieten würden,
dass wir uns die einzelnen
Sicherheitsbehörden individueller
anschauen und nicht alle
Sicherheitsbehörden in einen Topf werfen.
Sondern uns anschauen, was braucht
es für Veränderungen, beispielsweise beim
Verfassungsschutz? Da gibt es ja
verschiedene politische Ideen, z.B.
auch von Abschaffung, sehr radikal,
bis Reform, die aber alle irgendwie nicht
klappen, weil es eine Immunisierung
gibt, dass man diese Behörden überhaupt nicht
anfassen darf. Gleichzeitig müssen
wir schauen, was kann man bei der Polizei
verändern, was kann man beim
BKA verändern? Und gleichzeitig
auch die Politik z.B. mit parlamentarischer
Kontrolle stärker
in die Pflicht nehmen, wenn es diese Möglichkeit
gibt. Weil oftmals wird
das auch von Seiten der Behörden
torpediert. Und ganz wichtig:
Auch die Zivilgesellschaft stärker in die Verantwortung
ziehen, weil letztendlich
in unserer Gesellschaft wir als Zivilgesellschaft
dafür Sorge tragen,
dass so etwas nicht passieren kann,
dass rechtsextremer Terror im Keim erstickt
wird in gewisser Weise. Und ich glaube,
da braucht es ein Zusammenspiel von Politik,
Gesellschaft, aber auch von Sicherheitsbehörden,
das ich aktuell nicht
so sehe und was zu einem massiven
Vertrauensverlust in sehr, sehr vielen
-Bereichen der Gesellschaft führen kann.
-Das war der Kompromissvorschlag der grünen
Seite. Ihr könnt euch jetzt gerne dazu
positionieren, einen Schritt auf die grüne
Seite zugehen. Daniel ist der einzige,
der einen Schritt geht. Warum?
Ja, weil ich glaube, dass ganz viele
wichtige Punkte genannt sind. Zum einen
auch in der Debatte zu differenzieren
und zum anderen auch sozusagen ein Strauß
von von Möglichkeiten, wie wir die Schwierigkeiten,
die wir im Moment
mindestens subjektiv, aber auch viele
objektive Fehler, die wir im Moment haben,
-konkret angehen können.
-Stephan, warum bist du keinen Schritt auf
-die andere Seite zugegangen?
-Ruben hat eine ganze Menge, oder die
Gruppe besser gesagt, hat eine ganze
Menge wichtiger Punkte angesprochen, wo wir gar
nicht so weit entfernt sind von dem,
was wir auch vorschlagen werden. Aber was mir
immer noch so ein bisschen
bitter aufstößt, ist, dass immer noch so
mitschwingt mehr Kontrolle,
einzeln auf den Topf setzen. Ich glaube,
dass das nicht zielführend ist. Ich gebe
nur ein Beispiel Wir haben während des NSU
z.B. im Verfassungsschutz genau so
eine parlamentarische Kontrolle gehabt,
ein Innenministerium, was eine Fachaufsicht
gehabt hat. Und ich kann
nur sagen, wenn die alle nicht
mitbekommen haben, was da abgeht, dann waren
entweder die Verfassungsschützer sehr klandestin
unterwegs oder die haben alle
-gepennt. Also mit anderen Worten
-Vielleicht war es eine Mischung aus
-beidem.
-Oder eine Mischung aus beidem. Wir sind
beim Kompromiss, gerne. Aber Fakt
ist an dieser Stelle, ich glaube, noch mehr
Kontrolle, als wir jetzt schon haben,
wird das Problem nicht lösen. Aber ich denke,
-wir haben einige Aspekte gelöst.
-Aber was bringt eine Kontrolle, wenn zum
Beispiel vonseiten
der Behörden gemauert wird?
Wir können ja gar nicht mauern. Ich werde
regelmäßig einmal im Monat auf den Topf
gesetzt von der parlamentarischen
Kontrolle.
Wenn Aussagen zum Beispiel von Zeug_innen
von vornherein unter Druck gesetzt werden
und so weiter, das überhaupt nicht
in Untersuchungsausschüssen, das ans Licht
-kommen kann.
-Das ist richtig, da gebe ich dir recht, da
-muss man dann
-Dann kannst du einen Schritt auf ihn
-zugehen.
-Na gut. Dann muss aber wirklich auch mal
schauen, was können diese Untersuchungsausschüsse,
was dürfen sie?
Und ich bin jetzt mal ganz böse:
Welche fachliche Kompetenz haben diejenigen,
die in den Ausschüssen sitzen
und all das hinterfragen sollen?
Bevor wir zu eurem
Kompromissvorschlag kommen, Axel, jetzt hast du dich doch
einen kleinen Schritt bewegt, hätte
ich dich gerne nochmal gefragt, warum du dich
-nicht direkt bewegt hast.
-Also ich kann auch bei vielen Dingen
zustimmen, nur ich finde die Erwartungshaltung
zu hoch gegriffen.
Wir werden rechtsextremem Terror
genauso wenig im Keime generell ersticken können
wie islamistischen Terror oder linksextremen
Terror. Ich bin auch kein
Freund davon, immer das so auf die Behörden
abzuwälzen und zu sagen,
wir müssen jetzt die Polizei, das LKA
und den Verfassungsschutz auf den Kopf
stellen. Die Gerichte gehören
genauso dazu. Ich habe das damals selber oft
erlebt, dass viele Dinge, wo die Polizei
mir einen Denkzettel verpassen wollte,
dann die Gerichte angerufen worden und gesagt
haben, von wegen hier ist gegessen,
Junge, du kannst marschieren, du
kannst machen, was du willst. Und da muss viel
breiter angesetzt werden, weil Rechtsextremismus
oder andere Extremisten
sind vor allem deswegen attraktiv, weil sie Jugendlichen
eine Erlebniswelt bieten.
Und der beste Verfassungsschutz der Welt
und die demokratischste Polizeieinheit
der Welt kann da nicht einschreiten,
wo gesellschaftliche Probleme dann am Bach
sind. Und deswegen halte ich es für kurz
gegriffen und auch die Erwartungshaltung
-einfach zu hoch.
-Ihr könnt jetzt auch gerne euren
-Kompromissvorschlag präsentieren.
-Wir haben uns ausgetauscht, dass wir
eigentlich einen bunten Strauß an Unternehmungen,
Maßnahmen, wie auch immer
man es nennen möchte, brauchen, die einerseits
zivilgesellschaftlich sind:
Also breites Bewusstsein für die Problematik,
Jugendämter müssen gestärkt
werden, die ganze kommunale Ebene
muss gestärkt werden, um einfach sozusagen
diese Entwicklung früher abzugreifen.
Das ist das eine. Und dann eben, wir haben
hier auch heute wieder Vertreter von zwei
Sicherheitsbehörden. Es gibt aber noch
viel, viel, viel mehr. Und insbesondere bei der Polizei
auch die Justizbehörden,
die die Ermittlungsverfahren auch leiten,
von denen wir abhängig sind.
Wo wir als Polizei manchmal auch einfach
auf verlorenem Posten sind,
weil die Justiz nicht
dem folgt, was wir vorschlagen.
Das war der Kompromissvorschlag der gelben
Seite. Ihr könnt euch jetzt wiederum gerne
-dazu positionieren.
-Ich bin ein bisschen zwiegespalten bei
dem, was gesagt worden ist.
Zum einen, weil ich ein Problem sehe,
weil wenn wir über
zivilgesellschaftliches Engagement reden, dann ist es sehr,
sehr häufig, dass wenn man
beispielsweise eine Gegendemonstration gegen einen
Neonaziaufmarsch macht, man von Polizei
als Störenfriede gesehen wird. Und man
wird eigentlich als die Ursache
des Problems gesehen. Nicht, dass dort
-irgendwelche Neonazis marschieren.
-Vielleicht kann ich ihn dazu bewegen und
wir gehen beide noch ein Schrittchen
nach vorne und landen dann dort, du musst aber
ein Riesenschritt machen. Ich glaube,
was ganz wichtig ist, dass wir solche Runden,
wie wir sie jetzt hier gehabt haben
- mit Moderation, die ausgezeichnet war,
aber vielleicht auch ohne -brauchen,
damit wir mal gegenseitig aus den Schützengräben
rauskommen. Die Behörden sehen nicht
immer nur die Zivilgesellschaft als den Feind
auf der anderen Seite. Und vielleicht
ein Stück weit auch die Zivilgesellschaft,
die anfängt, ein Stück weit
vielleicht sich in eine Position hineinzuversetzen.
Warum stellen sich Behörden so an,
wie sie sich vielleicht manchmal anstellen?
Was für Menschen aus Nicht-Behörden
oftmals nicht nachvollziehbar ist.
Dass diejenigen, die es jetzt wirklich
betrifft, dann die Justiz und Jugendämter
und andere noch mit eingeschlossen,
dass man sich wirklich mal zusammensetzt
und auch einfach mal zuhört,
was die Einzelnen zu erzählen haben,
was sie umtreibt, was sie bewegt, um daraus
ein Stück weit auch zu entwickeln:
Hey, hoppla, vielleicht sind wir gar
nicht so weit auseinander und der Schritt
aufeinander zu ist viel einfacher
möglich, als wir uns das vielleicht im Moment alle
-vorstellen.
-Aber was mich so ein bisschen stört an
dieser ganzen Debatte über
gesamtgesellschaftliche Verantwortung ist,
auf der einen Seite haben wir Behörden
mit einem Gewaltmonopol,
mit Ermittlungskompetenzen,
mit im Zweifelsfall Waffen,
die sie bei der Durchsetzung der Interessen
des Staates einsetzen dürfen.
Auf der anderen Seite haben wir die Gesellschaft,
die breit aufgestellt ist.
Es gibt Menschen, die eher von rechtem
Terror betroffen sind als andere.
Und da diese Verantwortung sozusagen
gleichmäßig aufteilen zu wollen, das finde
ich verkehrt. Also ich möchte, dass wir sozusagen
aus dieser Runde herausgehen
und sagen: Die Latte, die wir an die Behörden
stellen, ist weitaus höher
als die, die wir im Rest
der Gesellschaft stellen.
Ich gehe einen Schritt vor. Ich bin
mit ihr völlig einer Meinung. Wir haben
als Behörden eine besondere
Verantwortung und dieses Diskussionsangebot,
was ich jetzt machen wollte, heißt auf gar
keinen Fall, dass ich das ausgleichen
will. So nach dem Motto, ihr seid
genauso dafür zuständig wie wir da drüben,
sage ich mal, in der Zivilgesellschaft.
Das ist was anderes. Und trotzdem sage
ich, am Ende, wenn wir nicht
miteinander kommunizieren und funktionieren,
werden wir dieses Problem nicht
gelöst kriegen. Aber wir haben eine besondere
Verantwortung als Behörden. Ich möchte,
dass die Sicherheitsbehörden auf allen
Ebenen besser werden. Ich möchte,
dass unsere Gesellschaft eines Tages so frei
wie möglich von rechtsextremen
Tendenzen ist. Ich möchte, dass es unabhängige
Stellen gibt, an die ich mich als jemand,
der z.B. von Machtmissbrauch durch
Polizistinnen und Polizisten
betroffen ist, wenden kann. Und ich möchte,
dass dieser Beschwerde dann
auch konsequent und ergebnisorientiert
und offen nachgegangen wird und dass es derzeit
noch nicht der Fall.
Ich würde mir auch wünschen, dass wir das tatsächlich
auch in unserem Alltag
regelmäßig einbauen können, dass wir mit Communities
ins Gespräch kommen,
die vielleicht kritisch auf die Sicherheitsbehörden
blicken und dann eben
auch ein gegenseitiges
Verständnis vielleicht herstellen können.
-Ich stehe jederzeit bereit.
-Sehr gut.
Ich bedanke mich auf jeden
Fall sehr bei euch für die Diskussion.
-Danke für die Moderation.
-Die Diskussion hat wie so oft schon
gezeigt, dass die Zeit, die wir hier
bei 13 Fragen haben, nicht reicht, um so
ein Problem einfach zu lösen. Wir können
ein paar Kompromissvorschläge machen,
die vielleicht fruchten, auch bei euch
im Kopf. Und dann müssen wir die Diskussion
einfach weiterführen. Welche Argumente
haben euch denn überzeugt? Schreibt's uns
in die Kommentare und falls euch die Diskussion
angeregt hat, dann lasst doch
sehr gerne ein Abo da für diesen Kanal.
Hier oben findet ihr ein weiteres Video
von 13 Fragen und hier unten ein weiteres
Video zum Thema.